good marine grounds Tuesday I don't know
what day it is but I'm wearing short
sleeves because I'm in Florida but tiny
chickens have all but fled my system now
they're only taking residence currently
in my larynx so I'm a little bit but
other than that I'm feeling quite well
thank goodness Pathan I want to talk
about today because apparently the
president of PETA recently rewrote her
will and I was fascinated to read all of
the different things that she put in her
will
for example she would like the meat of
her body to be used as meat mmm
PETA man me frankly I think this is a
fine idea and not only that she wants
her hide to be used in purses she wants
her legs to be used in umbrella stands
and she wants to send her eye to the US
Environmental Protection Agency so that
they know that she's watching them I
mean I am in favor of Peters mission and
as you know I love meat I love corn dogs
oh that's good but John I want to tell
you something about this corn dog
there's no meat in it and I don't know
what it's gonna taste like but I'm gonna
try it because I am 100% in favor of
Peter's cause I want people to eat less
meat ah
Oh hmm
hardly break up I wouldn't call her a
corn dog
well I'm surprisingly good especially
that I cooked in the microwave not you
pride weird how they should be cooked
also there's 67% less fat and a faint
court on that a real corn dog so I can
eat like three of them which I probably
will do kind of feel like this needs
mayonnaise gathering can you give me
some mayonnaise
well I suggest morningstar corn dogs to
all of you and they're not paying me to
say that John meat is bad and I'm sorry
to bring that news to you because I know
that you love meat the same way that I
do sometimes you even like blending it
all together with soda pop in drinking
it but John 80% of the agricultural land
in America is used to feed food 80% of
corn 90% of soy 70% of wheat goes
directly into the mouths of the things
that will go into our mouths and 50% of
the water in America is used to water
food that is fed to food oh man it's so
dramatically inefficient and especially
now that I know that these vegetarian
corn dogs
so delicious but I think the pious
problem is you create no meters and 100%
meters and then you get like five
percent of the people eating no meat and
95% of the people eating exactly as much
meat as they always ate this is not what
we need we need fifty percent of the
people or 100 percent of the people
eating 20 percent or 50 percent less
meat I've been thinking recently that
America needs some new nonprofit
organizations like the coalition to
never allow Beverly Hills Chihuahua to
be the only option for an in-flight
movie or the Coalition for a logarithmic
age scale so that you have more
birthdays when you're younger when you
like birthdays and fewer birthdays when
you're older when you don't want to
think about them I think that we need a
coalition of meat eaters for eating less
meat I'm never gonna give up corndogs
completely but I can do less I can eat
fewer hamburgers and steaks and chicken
sandwiches and all these things that I
don't love the way that I love corndogs
and we could all come back on the things
that we don't really love that we do
really need and it will do the world a
tremendous amount of good without really
hurting us at all it isn't about saving
cute and cuddly animals it's about
saving the freakin planet it takes 60
gallons of water to make a pound of
potatoes it takes 12,000 gallons of
water to make a pound of beef and we
don't have that water to spare we don't
have the energy to spare we don't have
the food to spare to support the
meat-eating of America especially when
there are delicious alternatives John
you'll see me tomorrow